hi guys my name is Tamra chambers and
I'm Kody Mel chair and this is Tamra
Jessa and Cody also just saw two as well
in Underpants John ah toady got we just
had a truck stop so she gave me the true
boss baby I want to know what it was
with the with the saris are these at
least jewel on my boss hand I thought my
denim boss well you're sure if it's real
dude I'm honestly today we went and saw
Captain Underpants yes the first epic
movie yes yeah we're going to see the
money we were but then all of this
happened
this is awful the last night super late
you text for you i I didn't say it but I
was feeling it but I was like I'm
leaving forever if I have this big man
sucks that we have to see this 20% of
rotten tomatoes we could even see like
Captain Underpants
specific business all it took was one
tag so yeah let's do that
this was like another Smurfs yes I mean
in like with a little bit of occasions
and was incredibly it was incredibly
joyful we both read the books growing up
back when I was saying back when you
could got like the scholastic like
catalogs at school and oh my god those
were what I lived for I was worried
because it was DreamWorks and with our
past DreamWorks boss baby sounds a
little worried but it was a surprising
delight I loved it I thought that the
lessons they taught were credible I
thought that the the friendship between
Herold and George George we're amazing
Kumar Harrelson Cooper did it as Harold
and I'm like uh no no Cody no different
duo with a Harold we had children in
this movie as well like we didn't have
children there were children present for
the film uh and they laughed at the
movie I'm like boss baby boy hey I
didn't like if you want to use you know
if you want to use a test subject for a
children's movie because like we can say
whatever we want
but like we definitely lasted a lot of
things the kids didn't laugh at because
there were some jokes in there obviously
for parents um or at least adults but
yeah like
there were children do Blatt like there
were several more for I'll ask at a kid
laughs like right at the beginning when
they first introduced Captain Underpants
like when he when the hypnosis happened
spoiler alert and he's like and he's
like happenin I would have another pan a
kid in the front like giggles maniacally
and it was amazing little and like
that's what you wanted a kid's movie you
want kids to enjoy it I don't think I'll
join I don't mean to blow your mind here
buddy what you want in a kids movie is
children to enjoy it too much Cody I
mean if I'm bringing the heat shots have
been fired
a little bit I had so much fun like
surveying the children that's a bad
sentence I had so much fun they were
having fun was really great the whole
time in the meadows comparing box baby
the last game works kids know anything
because it's two bald people they are
kind of similar except for one glaring
difference which is that one of them is
a better booth
just the one it started off and
immediately you could tell that they had
written in an incredible friendship with
these two boys who genuinely loved each
other
really it was it was so nice to see they
were like the tamarin Cody of Katherine
under yeah ordered each other's are uh
it was adorable
they were the favored Cody are we
getting a vegetable I wish I had that
growing out yeah it wasn't my dog my dog
was my Herald ago I got my pet rat
yogurt was mine I had a parrot growing a
big Twinkie cupcake that doesn't
surprise me at all my brother and I
wanted to name it
well we both had different names we when
neighbors my mom's just like--all dis
name it photos of it for some reason my
brother and I were trying to argue
between Twinkie and because it was very
young yeah right
I don't know how to explain remember the
six years older than me he wanted dreams
come on that got him about it I was a
child
this movie was just so earnest and silly
and so like all of the emotional stuff
was earned be
if you cared about these kids it's so
overblown the whole point of the movie
is that they're going to put them in
separate classes they live next to each
other they hang out all the time after
school and their whole world lemons are
like our world's going to end because
I'm like the actual world's going to end
because we're not going to spend class
either we're never going to see each
other when I'm going to remember who we
are and recognize each other and like
it's obviously so silly but you do feel
for these kids yeah so the animation
style similar to box maybe change
several times they do puppets they do
much other stuff
but those are earned because it's either
the way the kids are telling the story
is affected by that like when they do
the puppets because Harold has socks and
they do sock puppets embossing I liked
the animation differences because it was
like to me the only enjoyable parts
right stylistic choice and this it was
like oh man it just adds to cuz it just
keeps going because it made sense in the
film right father maybe was like the
cart before the horse like it was like
you could tell that everything was
because the plot needed to happen or it
was a stylistic decision and this was
all driven by the relationship in the
whole point of the movie is George and
Harold are basically telling you this
story and it felt like a movie that I
would like the two smart witty kids were
telling me like I felt like it was their
busy days children telling the story but
they were wives children and yeah and
and there were so much fun in that like
in the very beginning you start off and
you see their friendship you see the
pranks they pull you see their treehouse
in the comics they create you see one of
them writes the stories and one does the
art and then they love each other for it
is really sweet I know it is all I love
it's also supported
over all those little houses a
house it looks like a really good tailor
I know really okay
in sixth grade this was like a really
sad moment in Cameron's life sixth grade
I was put in a class and every single
one of my friends we had like a group of
five girls that were friends and they
were all put in the other class and then
we were not friends after that and they
were like really mean to me it was like
overtly like six rings awful I never
went outside for recess I stayed in a
red it was
terrible and so the whole time I was
like oh my god I did not know that about
your emotional state yeah yeah yeah so I
was like oh like in it to win it I was
very much supported I didn't I didn't
need to be inciting incident I just
existed basically as a sad quiet
character at school sad my worst fears
were first through whatever you call the
fourth year of college what's your
school I am right now
Jeremy this children's movie is really
gone doing this is not an actual
criticism but it is like kind of a
criticism so the whole thing is that
George and Harold played pranks all the
time but and they show you a bunch of
the pranks as they pull and sort of them
I'm like you know what I'm on the side
of the administration on this one
putting a tiger in a classroom is not
good they steal a crane and destroy a
lot of private property and I'm like
okay we've just moved into crimes I
think the principal definitely ovary
effects to some extent I think is a
middle ground we could file so like
Melvin is it the the nerdy kid is a
genius and is treated like a jerk the
whole time because it as a medicine for
humor like he should be pitied a little
like he's he's a full-on genius I
studied him in the movie for sure so
that's all weird it's like a thing I
talked about a lot on stage is this idea
that like you know bullies bullies don't
get children's movies and so it just
makes them worse bullies because it's
like every bully and I'm not saying like
we should pity the bullies necessarily
but there are still children I guess I
guess like in the question whether
they're actually children he's not even
a bully he's just a nerd know that if I
was like a like I would have been melded
not sort of a kiss-up you know but like
and I'm a sense of humor I guess but I'm
in a friend that's Melvin that's like
you got a 10 shoe I would have
identified with right and I said
likewise I really wanna know
taking a Melvin out of that equation
they were really kind to all of the
students and they were like doing these
pranks to help other kids and Robin
hoodie yeah yeah it felt really nice and
really like they would support anyone
who needed support also
no I thought there was like a good range
of students who work just like all white
students yeah tonight I I can't believe
the difference between this and boss
baby
story-wise is just I may compare the Jew
story-wise in comedy-wise like I'll set
like I don't like I said earlier I don't
really like toilet humor like you know
scatological and flatulence humor is
this something I've never really found
funny I'm not a problem here at
illogical yeah that's like fecal related
comedy anyway so I I think it's that's
your bag go for it bro but like this is
not what I find funny I you know just in
the same way that like I'm sure you
wouldn't you all probably wouldn't enjoy
my Anabaptist rebellion jokes but like
there's different things we're all into
different things and but this movie was
so silly until like sweet that you know
and it's kind of like when when those
windows hardcore like flatulence jokes
came up like the the the concert was the
whoopee cushions right that was I just
like you know rolled my eyes I went oh
you guys like that you know like I
wasn't like so like oh this isn't funny
I'm out of it it was like they earned it
at that point and Jimmy you're the the I
wouldn't call that bad yeah they're gone
but there's actually no one in the
theatre was laughing at the flatulence
acquire so I think that that was just
kind of more of a mist yeah that you not
liking yeah I think it is so yeah it was
a silly the caps was great the voice
acting cast was awesome they which is
such a good job and it was just sweet
like if they think us or laughter back
and the boys are like Oh feels so good
to laugh oh it's simple kinda cranky
where I'm gonna wear this year wedding
that has gonna be catters it's gonna be
dust doesn't by the time I get married
anything naughty might leave in like
that case oh my god
no the Boz hat is the service it is
impoverished I have to get married
before the boss completely fall the love
story from Millennials hey Liz oldest
Twitter thanks for watching
guys I give it five waistbands
okay I give it 19 panes boxer briefs out
of 28 Victoria Secrets trying to Rack my
brain for all the underwear brand spy
[Music]
you